My first thought when I saw the new 2019 iPad
Air show up on Apple’s website was, wow,
this thing’s basically a 2017 iPad Pro but
with fewer features, so I recommended that
instead of the new Air, but since then, I’ve
realized that not everyone wants a used or
refurbished 2-year old iPad, and although
the A10X chip in the iPad Pro will last many
years, the A12 in the new iPad Air will last
longer, and it’s fresh and brand new.
I’ve realized that the $500 price tag really
isn’t that bad for what you get, considering
that the extra power of the 2018 iPad Pro
won’t be noticed unless you’re doing something
like video editing.
We played games on both iPads and didn’t
really notice a difference in available graphics
quality and smoothness of gameplay.
Both of them could easily play certain games
at 60 frames per second and even PUBG at maxed
out graphics.
No issues at all on the iPad Air.
The 2019 iPad Mini packs the same A12 processor
as the iPad Air but for $100 cheaper, which
is a great deal if you’re okay with the
smaller display, and in my review of the iPad
Mini, I called it the best tablet ever for
gaming, even more so than the new iPad Pro,
because of the lightweight and easy to hold
form factor.
The Mini and Air are basically identical iPads
except for two things, the size and the fact
that the Air gets a smart connector for use
with Apple’s high-quality smart keyboard.
The Mini is so small that typing on a Bluetooth
keyboard won’t really be comfortable at
all.
Other than that, they’re the same exact
iPad.
The displays are absolutely fantastic and
much better than the 2018 budget iPads display.
However, the smaller display of the Mini is
definitely a drawback for certain things,
so that’s why it’s worth it for some people
to pay the extra $100 for iPad Air.
If you’re into note taking or drawing, the
Mini’s display feels pretty limiting in
that regard.
I don’t think people realize just how much
smaller the display is compared to the iPad
Air.
Video content is much smaller, doing schoolwork
or spreadsheets may be a bit more difficult
and you see less on the screen while browsing
the web.
So the 2019 iPad Air is a great choice for
those who need a larger display but don’t
want to pay for the new iPad Pro.
The biggest problem is that iOS is currently
very limiting so you can’t really use your
iPad as a computer replacement, at least not
yet.
Now let’s take a look at what we can expect
in the future.
iOS 13 is gonna be revealed soon, and it looks
like there are some iPad features coming that
are gonna boost productivity and multitasking
on the iPad.
Of course, there’s the rumored Dark Mode
feature, but I want to focus on productivity
features.
For example, it looks like we’re finally
getting multiple app window support.
So that means you can have two instances of
google docs open, or two safari windows, two
spreadsheets, and much more, and you can move
them around the screen, just like you can
do on a real computer.
Safari will be able to automatically ask for
a desktop version of websites to avoid compatibility
issues on certain websites.
And we’re finally getting a real undo gesture,
because who’s gonna be shaking their iPad
to undo text.
That’s ridiculous.
Apple’s also rumored to be adding a new
font manager, and they’re making improvements
to document collaboration in third-party apps.
The Mail app is getting some worthy desktop-like
improvements as well, and it seems like Apple
is finally gonna add a way to quickly select
multiple items in various views, just like
click and drag works on macOS.
We should also expect a new and much more
useful volume HUD as well since the current
one really sucks.
As you can tell from these changes, Apple
is really focusing on improving workflow and
allowing people to actually replace their
laptops much more easily.
Now if you’re using these features and working
with multiple windows, being limited to the
iPad Mini’s display isn’t gonna be fun.
That’s why I think the Air is the better
choice for people who do use it for studying,
typing, business or multitasking.
And we can even look further to iOS 14 and
what features that’ll be adding.
I’m sure the extra screen real estate will
serve you better in the years to come.
Now if you don’t do much of that, like let’s
say you do a lot of gaming, and you like the
portability of the iPad Mini, then that’s
still a great choice for some people, especially
since you save $100.
And talking about the new iPad Pro, I still
think it’s overkill for almost everyone,
even after iOS 13 and 14 are released.
The A12 in the iPad Air is a very powerful
chip and it’ll be more than good enough
for most people for years to come.
Now what are some drawbacks of the 2019 iPad
Air?
Well, the main thing is that it’s still
using the same old home button-packing design.
To me, it’s really not that big of a deal.
The design still looks, feels and works great.
Another downside is that it’s only packing
two speakers on the bottom, unlike 4 speakers
on the iPad Pro.
It sucks but it makes sense why Apple would
keep that exclusively for the iPad Pro, just
like the ProMotion technology.
Other than that, there’s really nothing
to complain about with the iPad Air.
It’s a fantastic all-around iPad that offers
basically everything you’ll need to do iPad
things, with an incredibly bright and color
accurate display.
So here’s my recommendation.
If you don’t care much for the iPad Pro’s
extra features and you want to do some drawing,
note-taking, typing or multitasking, I would
definitely buy the new iPad Air over every
other iPad in Apple’s 2019 lineup.
Now if your budget is limited, you can pick
up the 2018 budget iPad for only around $250-$280
brand new, but you’ll have to compromise
on things like display quality and a bit of
performance.
If you enjoyed this review, make sure to hit
that button to subscribe and check out some
of our in-depth iPad comparison videos.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next video.